FRANCIS SCOTT KEY,
A VERY PROMINENT LAWYER
IN BALTIMORE
DURING THE 1812 WAR.
ONE NIGHT, HIS BROTHER-IN-LAW
SHOWS UP, AND HE SAYS,
FRANCIS, THE HONORABLE
DR. BEANES
HAS BEEN TAKEN CAPTIVE ON
A BRITISH WARSHIP.
DR. BEANES IS A VERY UPSTANDING
MEMBER OF THE COMMUNITY.
HE HELPED EVERYBODY.
[laughs]
- HE'S DR. BEANES.
HE'S AMAZING.
FRANCIS SCOTT KEY GOES
TO PRESIDENT JAMES MADISON,
WHO WAS THE PRESIDENT
AT THE TIME.
HE SAYS, LISTEN, THE HONORABLE
DR. BEANES HAS BEEN KIDNAPPED.
PRESIDENT JAMES MADISON IS LIKE,
THE--IT'S LIKE A TERRIBLE--
LIKE, YEAH.
OBVIOUSLY, YOU GOT TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT THIS.
[laughing]
AND SO HE HOOKS HIM UP
WITH A GUY NAMED JA--
JOHN SKINNER,
A PRISONER EXCHANGE AGENT.
AND THEY SET SAIL
TO THE BRITISH HEADQUARTERS,
WHICH IS A [bleep] BOAT.
UNDER THE CONTROL
OF VICE "ADMIRABLE--"
UH, VICE "ADMIRABLE"--
UH, F--SORRY.
ADMIRAL A--
OH, OKAY, LET'S BACK UP.
VICE ADMIRAL ALEXANDER COCHRANE.
MAN, I'M [bleep] DRUNK.
I GOT TO DRINK MORE.
THE BRITISH WINE THEM,
AND THEY DINE THEM,
AND KEY AND SKINNER
AND WERE LIKE,
YOU'VE GOT THIS FRAIL,
OLD DOCTOR MAN
SITTING IN HIS CELL
OR WHATEVER.
IT'S LIKE, LET THE GUY GO,
YOU KNOW?
THEY MADE A REALLY GOOD CASE.
AND MAJOR GENERAL ROSS WAS LIKE,
SOUNDS GOOD.
LET'S LET DR. BEANES GO.
THEY WINED AND DINED
A LITTLE BIT MORE.
EVENTUALLY, KEY AND SKINNER HEAR
SOME BRITISH SOLDIERS SAYING,
YOU KNOW WHAT?
NEXT WEEK, WE'RE GONNA BE
ATTACKING BALTIMORE.
WE'RE GONNA BE
AND THEY SAW MAPS AND PLANS
OF HOW THEY WERE GONNA DO IT.
COCHRANE TELLS KEY AND SKINNER,
YOU KNOW TOO MUCH.
HE AND SKINNER WERE HELD
PRISONER FOR A FULL WEEK.
THEY WOULD TEASE THEM
AND SAY THINGS LIKE,
HEY, I HOPE YOU TAKE A GOOD LOOK
AT THAT FLAG OVER THERE,
BECAUSE, UM,
IT'S NOT GONNA BE THERE.
'CAUSE IT'S GONNA BE GONE.
[laughs]
SORRY.
FRANCIS SCOTT KEY IS THINKING--